[Music]  Klose Gannett six of our northern cities  had fallen in a coordinated attack their  leader fights alongside a witch  crush these murderers your majesty every  family must contribute one man to fight  your war hero you've already made many  great sacrifices  my father cannot fight so I will take  his place the northern invaders will  kill her if I expose how powerful people  will kill her when we take the Imperial  City I will take revenge for my father  what is your name soldier  watch it commander so no Quadro you will  now take the oath of the warrior  release  [Music]  [Music]  by pretending to be something you're not  yet here I stand proof that there is a  place for people like us  a girl threatens our plants  a warrior  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you